thanks for the invitation from microsoft
it's my great pleasure to present
application of ai in healthcare industry
in china i will present
from the perspective of a medical doctor
and also from the pharma industry my
name is cheonminghu i'm the head of
medical affairs with china for sanofi
china healthcare industry is undergoing
a fundamental change
from the economic development chennai is
already
always the second largest economy in the
world this will trick the increasing
demand on the treatment drug assessed
and the life quality of the people
especially the middle class people
on the demographic shift
china is moving to an aging population
is said by 2030 there will be 230
million people in china
the demand increase increasing and also
the medical is expenditure is also
increasing
china is a single-payer market
and
we have a much wider coverage almost
everyone get medical insurance and also
deeper reimbursement this will lead
increase of the medical expenses
and there's a lot of medical related
policies coming out recently
and this will encourage the drug
innovation especially the first-in-class
best-in-class drugs
and also china drug approval is getting
faster
and it's much closer to us fda approval
or
europe ema approve
and with the first development of a
technology the ai the cloud the 5g iot
blah blah and china healthcare industry
is undergoing a fundamental
transformation the first one is the
patient-centric it's from the
physician-centric to patient-centric the
digital trans transformation especially
the automation of the digital process
and
increase a lot of efficiency of the
healthcare industry
is coming into a data-driven
intelligence which will support the
precision medicine intent
there are a lot of emerging trends in
healthcare sector i will focus on some
areas from the research to the
development and to the patient journey
from the screening diagnosis treatment
and also patient adherence to the
treatment
from the pharma aspect the digitalized r
d digitalized pharma operation
the real world evidence
and is getting very important
and it's a complementary to the
randomized control trials the rct to
collect the data to support the clinical
decision
knowledge graph is also another very
powerful tools to support the clinical
decision and also use that when in
research and the development
clinical trials is also undergoing a
fundamental change from the face-to-face
clinical trials to the patient-centric
data treatment trials and also the
remote one for the virtual trials
another trend emerging very quickly from
recent years than the digital
therapeutic i will explain this one
later
internet hospital is booming in china we
have more than one of the internet
hospitals in just in two or three years
and the clinical decision supporting
system already
applied in many hospitals in china to
support the physician's clinical
decision especially in the remote areas
and the county level hospitals patient
self-disease management also getting
very important from the
physician-centric to the 3d
patient-centric
for the ai ecosystem we start with the
data we use the multi-modal data source
including the emr the patient registry
data claim data the present data that is
the social media data and also the
genomic data is very important to
putting all these data together combined
with the medical knowledge the treatment
guidelines the lead reach of
publications then we can deliver develop
a lot of tools
that develop a lot of
models to predict and to guide the
clinical decision to support patient
experience
and use all these applications in
research and development for example the
target selection the clinical trial
management and also the hospital and
disease management and also the medical
insurance support for example the policy
analysis
rational drug use and the precision
medical insurance
use
for the digitalized r d is based on the
big data and also ai you know the r d is
a very very
time consuming and also budget consuming
normally it takes 10 to 15 years
and spent 1 billion to 1.5 billion usd
to develop one drug so it's very very
expensive to develop one drug so
ai usage in this
r d part is boomi and we have a lot of
a lot of companies under each pillars
but this is only least a few there are
many other companies is coming out in
china is the same
and it's covering from the basic
research the target selection and also
the drug
optimization and also the formulation
maximization for clinical trial part
that's the development part from the
patient's recruitment protocol
development data collection clinical
trial operation data analysis and the
drug restoration all along this r d
process the a is also and using which
will lead
thirty to forty percent
pair success rate and also forty two
fifty percent time saving and also 50
cost saving
where the the big
tech companies are also doing this we
see like google
microsoft amazon even ibm also
apply the aaa from drug discovery
clinical development the supply chain
the product launch and also monitoring
the clinical health record i will not go
into in detail one typical example
that's a diplomat to predict the protein
and
the folding of the protein or structure
of a protein and a very famous case and
leading the development of the ai use in
the drug development
and this is one case from us we're
working with the chinese academy our
science
and we use the draw and knowledge graph
to assist in the
the potential indication development we
combine the knowledge from the compound
our drug with the denied genomic data
with the disease-related data and also
putting all the data together we have
the knowledge graph and you can see
clearly we can find the all the
really possible indications relate to
this disease and also relate to this
compound we use our exciting indications
to test
this
algorithm and the same time we find a
lot of potential indications in the list
now we are working with the scientists
with the physicians in different
therapeutic areas to verify
the possible indications that we think
this is another way to support us for
the future education development
the transforming the clinical trials is
transforming from the digital
traditional trials to the virtual trials
you know the traditional trials we have
a lot of process from patient
recruitment
from the
baseline screening inform consent and
the scent signature and the treatment
group assignment and also treatment
patient follow-up so this takes a lot of
time and they use a lot of people and
ftes
use a lot of cras to support the
traditional files but for the virtual
trials for the data collection we don't
use the crf we use it for example use
the smartphones
use the app to collect all the data and
from the
from the bear markers and from different
organs that we can also use the patient
reporter outcome to collect data you see
the fundamentally changed for the data
collection and also we can use the
remote monitoring of the clinical trials
so this will save a lot of time and much
more
efficient for the digital marketers can
support us in every step of the patient
journey from the
disease prediction the diagnosis the
treatment the prognosis and even digital
therapeutic i will introduce one later
and this is one example we work with
engine hospital that's the
cardiovascular hospital the leading one
in china for the intro fabric from
february relation we predict the
the onset of a stroke for the patient
you see here we compare with the
framingham model we use our model at the
very beginning it's already better than
framingham model once we have the
feature selection the prediction
accuracies is getting better once we
increase
our variables from 50 to 100 150 200 you
see the accuracy also increasing the
difference is the framingham model use
only five variables that's why we use
the aes support machine learning can
have a much better outcome compared with
the traditional framingham model
another cases is the clinical decision
supported system you know traditionally
we use our personal knowledge and the
personal experience to treat a patient
now we can translate the personal
knowledge into the code which our
computer can really understand all the
knowledge
and use the natural language processing
we can read the medical emr and also
subtract the useful information into the
data set then we can do the analysis to
the patient's similarity and find the
best treatment solution for each single
patient from this case we did this one
in 1950 91 in 1995 we did this one in
xiamen city the xiamen city they have
four four million people and they have a
con district hospitals we compare with
the 19 hospital district with another 19
district with cds support you see after
even three months we can see
and there's a
significant difference and the
cholesterol control also have a
significant better compared with the
control arm for diabetes control for
hypertension control we got the same
result so click decision support really
very effective to supporting the county
hospital and disease management
another
example that's the uh what we are doing
in sanofi that's a diabetes management
program we call the trio the meaning is
trill that means three people including
physician including the nurse and also
the patient we putting the three of them
together to manage the disease once the
patient gets a treatment let's say for
insulin injection the nurse will support
them
to how to use the insulin pen to inject
the insulin how many units of energy
insulin can should be injected more in
importantly we have a iit platform and
using the
chatbot to support the patient if
patients have any questions you can ask
the chatbot if a headboard cannot answer
the question we use the wechat antenna
to inform the nurse a nurse can answer
the questions if the nurse cannot answer
questions we will link the patient to
the physician this will dramatically
increase efficiency and reduce the
workload for the physicians at the same
time we can not only manage
use the insulin but at the same time we
manage their death rate their excess
their sleep their mental
concern like depression so putting all
together we have a very good result
compared with the baseline three months
the day of treatment retention you see
dramatically compared from 49 to 76 the
hb81c level control from the 39.7 to 58
and also
fast plasma glucose achievement also
increasing dramatically
another emerging trend that's a digital
therapeutic which will be the future
innovation why use the digital
therapeutic because the health care
relief data for the patients only 10
percent and the geonomic data covers 30
percent another cd5 that's the behavior
related
environmental related other and the
social related data at the moment we
only care about the health care data but
neglect the large part with the digital
therapeutic we can put all these data
together to manage the patient that's
the emerging trend that we call the
digital therapeutica we use the clinical
evidence to show that digital
therapeutic can have a much better
effect compared with the standard care
so just like a medical we test a medical
drug
one example is the
the product
from achilles in u.s fd just approved
this one in 2020 last year they use the
video to treat the patients with adhd
for the keys they have a helper
activities and
attention deficiencies
you see that even with the tree with the
with the
green they can treat the disease this is
the typical digital therapy of course
many other ways for the digital
therapeutic
and the internet hospital as i mentioned
in the very beginning is booming for the
last two years china already have more
than one thousand internal hospitals uh
almost all the big hospitals we have
same time internal hospitals and other
technical giant they also have the
technic internet hospitals for the
application in the hospital really
support the patient seeking the the
treatment including the before the
hospital they have a pre-diagnosis
screening about of the disease even they
have a service assessment and the data
report and in the hospital and they will
have a red diagnosis of online diagnosis
online consultation even physicians have
online treatment and online labor tests
the patient can go to the offline real
hospitals have their on the real level
test and this
test can sync time can send back to the
online and
physicians and even after hospital we
have the doctor patient interactions
engagements and treatment adjustments
follow-up disease education you see all
along the patient journey which is the
total difference from the offline
treatment and it's a booming antenna and
the support a lot especially after
covida 19.
the last example that's the ems cells
for the pharmaceutical companies you
know we have a lot of medical rep now we
are doing the e-wrap and for the medical
team we use the medical science liaison
and we also have the e msl
so this is a virtual one
instead of the real msl we use the
virtualbox the key thing is like a three
one we have a 360 degrees understanding
of a key of our profile
and we have an automatic data content
generation for example we do need to
really go into the pubmed and the
machine can support us to search all the
the papers and the we same time under
the key our preference we have
individualized the the data
recommendation and send all these papers
to the
qrls so traditionally we use the
face-to-face offline events and the
third-party events now we in china we
use a lot another email and it's like
whatsapp in u.s and we use the wechat
very often in china to communicate with
each individual physicians and we can
same time we combine the offline with
online we call the hybrid msls and
online webinars which are used very
often
in china the efficiency is getting
improved customer preference the
customer experience improved a lot so
for today and this is my brief
introduction hope hopefully it will be
helpful for all of you thank you very
much and thank you for your attention
thanks again for the invitation from
microsoft